or O'Donnell is on Capitol Hill to
preview what looks like the most
high-profile congressional hearing in
years nor a good morning hey good
morning to you Gail I mean think about
this this is going to be the first time
that we're gonna hear and see the
college professor from California who
claims the judge Cavanaugh assaulted her
when they were teenagers we've only had
that picture before that one picture of
her with the sunglasses on so what we do
know is that Blasi Ford is going to tell
this committee in a statement I don't
remember as much as I would like to but
the details about that night that bring
me here today
are ones I will never forget that's part
of her opening statement Cavanaugh plans
to respond that he is not perfect
perfect but will say I never did
anything remotely resembling what dr.
Ford describes now on the eve of this
hearing hearing we are learning more
accusations against Cavanaugh Nancy
Cordes has been covering this nomination
battle since it began more than two
months ago and Nancy good morning good
morning and here's what's at stake for
Cavanaugh today you have multiple
Republican senators saying they need to
see what happens at this hearing before
they decide how they are going to vote
so his nomination is very much up in the
air at the same time they're processing
these new claims and even the president
for the first time is saying he could
change his mind I can't tell you whether
or not their lives until I hear them
president Trump said he's sticking by
Judge Brett Kavanaugh but he'd be swayed
by Blasi for sounds like what you're
saying is there is a situation there is
a scenario under which you would
withdraw Bret Cavanaugh's nomination if
I thought he was guilty of something
like this you're sure I can always be
convinced I have to hear it at the same
time he blamed the allegations on
Democrats they're actually con artists
because they know how quality this man
is and they've destroyed a man's
reputation and they want to destroy it
even more on Capitol Hill I'm not in a
good mood
tempers are flaring as Republicans
assess the damage from the latest
accusations what's your reaction I
haven't heard they're going to walk and
talk okay
let's knock it off for that 55 year-old
Julie sweat Nick claims that at high
school parties she witnessed Brett
Kavanaugh and others cause girls to
become inebriated and disoriented so
they could then be gang-raped in a side
room sweat Nick's lawyer is Michael
avenatti the idea that somehow all of
these women got together and conspired
to derail this nomination is absurd
Kavanagh forcefully denied those claims
in a transcribed phone interview with
Senate Judiciary investigators calling
the claims ridiculous a total Twilight
Zone
adding I've never participated in a gang
rape Democrats were skeptical what we
have here is really a pattern of vile
predatory
sexual misconduct on the eve of today's
hearing lawyers for professor Christine
Blasi Ford released results sent photos
from a polygraph test she took in August
according to her prepared remarks Ford
will tell the committee I was pushed
from behind into a bedroom at a
high-school party
Brett got on top of me and put his hand
over my mouth to stop me from screaming
this was what terrified me the most in
his prepared remarks Cavanaugh calls the
allegation a grotesque and obvious
character assassination I have never
sexually assaulted anyone not in high
school not in college not ever this is
getting into the twilight zone you're
talking about Brett cab now being a
serial rapist you're in high school many
committee Republicans have openly
expressed doubts about the accusers
Arizona Republican Jeff Flake urged both
sides to keep an open mind I do not
believe that judge Kavanagh is some kind
of serial sexual predator I don't
believe that dr. Ford is part of some
vast conspiracy Republicans on the
Judiciary Committee say they have spoken
to a man who believes he had an
encounter with Blasi Ford in 1982 and
that it wasn't Kavanaugh Democrats say
Republicans are releasing this anonymous
claim to undermine the allegations
against Kavanagh that's how polarized
this has all become and that's some new
information also this they're now a
couple of senators I understand who have
passed on allegations to the Senate
Judiciary Committee what do we know
about those claims are they
investigating them
these are anonymous claims that weren't
mailed to the senators from Colorado and
California they handed them over to the
Judiciary Committee it's important to
note that senators get stacks of
anonymous mail all the time and there's
no way to verify what these people are
saying about misconduct by Cavanaugh
because we don't know who they are
the committee did ask Kavanaugh about
their allegations and he denied them all
right Nancy Cordes thank you so much